un nouveau musée ouvert ses portes à
berlin pour les nostalgiques de
l'allemagne de l'est l'ex rda ou tout
simplement pour des touristes curieux de
la vie de tous les jours
à l'est avant la réunification du pays
seront bénies la sensation de conduire
une vraie traves ans sur les routes
d'allemagne
thomas et patricia l'avait oublié et
voilà que ses deux collègues de travail
qui ont grandi à l'est la retrouve
aussitôt la portière claqué normandie
puis livingsocial
quand on voit à quel point le pare brise
était petit on se demande comment on
pouvait voir la rue c'est le sentiment
d'être wathelet ce qui me frappe mais
par dessus tout ce que je ressens c'est
l'odeur de la trabant friche martre
arbitres
c'est la magie de ce tout nouveau musée
de la rda qui permet une plongée dans la
vie quotidienne de l'ancienne allemagne
communiste avec tous ces objets typiques
qui ont inondé le pays s'est couvert en
aluminium que l'on trouvait dans toutes
les cantines ou ses vêtements auquel
patricia s'estime heureuse d'avoir
échappé
j'avais quatre cousines à l'ouest on
avait tout un an d'écart et je recevais
bien sur leurs vêtements
on peut aussi s'installer dans le salon
époque et regarder le programme
hebdomadaire d'apologie du socialisme
même les gens de la r d un réel cela la
plupart en tout cas c'est un visiteur
pourtant plus âgés regrette cette époque
la vie en général ont été beaucoup plus
tranquille
aujourd'hui c'est déroutant qui est dit
un jour n'est plus vrai le moment alors
qu autrefois tout resté pareil pendant
des années on savait à quoi s'en tenir
et ça a aidé à vivre seule évocation de
la dictature dans le musée le poste des
coudes de la stasi la police secrète
est-allemande qui veillait de créer à ce
que tous restent toujours tranquille